[Music]
[Applause]
zach braff paid tribute to his close
friend Nick Cordero on Instagram Sunday
after the Broadway star lost his
month-long battle with the coronavirus
the scrubs alum shared this
black-and-white pick of Nick with his
wife Amanda klutz writing in the caption
that Nick died that morning with his
wife and mom by his side quote I have
honestly never known a kinder person but
Cova doesn't care about the purity of
your soul or the goodness in your heart
Nick and Zach starred together in
bullets over Broadway in 2014 which
earned Nick a Tony Award nomination for
Best Featured actor in a musical
[Music]
[Applause]
nobody
it was also where Nick first met Amanda
[Music]
the pair tied the knot in 2017 and
welcomed their son Elvis in 2019 Zach
revealed that the last thing his friend
texted him was to look out for his wife
and one-year-old son
I promised the world they will never
want for anything I feel so incredibly
grateful I got to have Nick Cordero
enter my life
rest in peace rest in power prior to his
death Zach had previously shared several
other posts about Nick as he fought for
his life including this pic of Amanda
and Elvis where he asked fans in the
caption to keep Nick in their thoughts
and prayers amanda shared the
heartbreaking news of her husband's
death on instagram writing that god has
another angel in heaven adding that
she's in disbelief and her heart is
broken elvis and i will miss him in
everything we do every day
you